hi there you're looking at Solaris which
is a game in the Atari benchmark and it
is has been one of the hardest games for
reinforcement learning agents to solve
what you're seeing is agent 57 which is
a new agent by deep mind that is the
first one to beat all of the 57 games in
the Atari suite to a human or a
superhuman performance so some of these
games have been you know pretty easy for
RL agents but some of them look at this
one here have been pretty hard mainly
because of the reward structure now you
see on the top top and top edge the
reward it's not going up for a long time
and this kind of games where the reward
doesn't go up for a long time it's very
hard for RL agents so 18:57 builds on a
number of previous improvements to the
original deep Q networks of deepmind and
today we'll look into this
so it's called 1857 as I said because it
eats all of these 57 games they're quite
diverse and it's it's it's a cool thing
that a single system can beat it so they
go into this this is a printout of the
website so I can scribble on it and this
here it's been cut off but it should say
DQ n here DQ n from 2015 2015
alright so this DQ n paper of 2015 was
kind of the original paper that
popularized this Atari benchmark and
introduced neural networks to
reinforcement learning basically that
made it work since then there have been
a number of improvements so maybe it
will just go into what the Q learning is
so in reinforcement learning usually you
have an agent and agent here and it you
have an environment
over here right and the environment will
give you an observation now the
observation in our case would be
something like the frame of a game right
and you're here you're a little rocket
and there is a bunch of meteors right
and then the agent needs to somehow give
back an action so an action and the
actions in the Atari benchmark are
always defined so you can in you know in
Atari you used to have this kind of
joystick thing you can put it up down
left right or you can put it like up
right up left and so on and also you
have a button I think one or two buttons
I don't actually remember but you do you
can press at least one button so these
are the actions let's say there is
something like 20 different actions so
all of the directions here and then you
can always press or not press a button
with it so you have to give yourself to
sent back this this action here you say
I want to you know put the joystick up
and I want to press the button at the
same time and then the environment will
give you back a it will say okay will
give you back a new observation which
would be the next frame of the game you
know you've pressed up so you're a
little rocket is a bit more forward
you've pressed the button so you fired a
shot and the meteors are still here and
it will also give you back a reward so
the reward different games give give
different rewards for example in pac-man
you know every time your pac-man eats a
little one of these dots you get a
reward but in other games most famously
games like Montezuma's Revenge you're in
this room and there are these platforms
and ladders and stuff you're here and
their opponents rolling around and there
is a door over here you don't need to go
down jump over here get up get some key
and then go to the door and
only then will you get a reward so games
very many in many ways in how you get
this reward so that's kind of the
intrinsic problem here so deep queue
learning is the following we have a
neural network taking in the observation
so we have a neural network let's
designate it as this and the observation
goes in here right this is oh the
observation goes in here and also the
action goes in here now let's call this
AI because we have different actions and
O observation at step T and it will give
you a Q value so the Q value for the
observation at time T and action I now
you do this for every single action so
you put observation with action AJ in
the same network right you get an you
get an output that is the Q value for
observation the same observation with
that's different action you do this for
every action and wherever the Q value is
the highest right wherever that's the
highest that's the action you go with so
what you have to do is you have to train
this neural network to predict the Q
value as accurate as possible and the Q
value is basically the reward that you
expect from now until the end of the
episode by performing this action in
this situation right that's Q learning
simply predicting if I do action I right
now how how much reward am I going to
get from now until the end of the
episode right that's that's basically it
that's deep and deep Q learning simply
because you have a neural network doing
the learning
so that was deep Q networks and they
work pretty well but they don't work for
these long time horizons because you
always just learn you just see one
observation right and you kind of
learned one step at a time and you
rely on this Q value is propagating
through from your experience it just it
doesn't work very well for these long
credit assignments now a significant
improvement upon that is this r2d2
algorithm that incorporated LST m/s or
in gr use which are recurrent neural
networks on not only does your
observation go into the neural network
right now you're a history of
observations so what you what happened
before so not only the current game
state right but here you have the
observation from step one the action you
did at that step then the observation
time to the action you did at time two
and so on they now all so this is
encoded and this is encoded and then you
have a recurrent neural network that
incorporates all of these things that
happened previously right into your
current representation so now not only
does the agency what is happening right
now it also gets the information of what
happened previously what did it do
previously and it can also now back
propagate through these things and kind
of learn a longer-range credit
assignment credit assignment means it
gets to figure out which actions had
actually an influence on the final
reward if you have if you incorporate
the history right you can have a direct
gradient flow across that history so
notably these these Ellis TMS or GRU is
you can let them you know compute over
maybe ten or a hundred steps right and
then you get a pretty good idea of which
of these actions within those hundred
steps led to which rewards and the other
thing on r2d2 is of course it is now
more distributed so this this was
already
here improvements to DQ n but the r2d2
agent is also distributed meaning that
you have like a central instance so this
is now engineering right you have a
central instance that is called the
learner and the learner has the main
weights which I wanted as it made with
theta here and it just takes in
experience from all of these workers
so there's worker one worker two or
three or four and so on and these they
will all just run episodes they will all
do work work work work work work work
work independently of each other and
then send back their experience to the
learner and every now and then the
learner sinks out the weights of the
neural networks to the workers so that's
kind of distributed RL in this in the
sense do you have a central learner then
you have many many workers doing the
actual interaction with the environment
so the the one of the main pitfalls of
r2d2 is still it has in poor exploration
exploitation strategy which I believe it
is still just kind of epsilon greedy
what does it mean so in order to
understand this maybe consider again our
screen here right so let's say you're
here with your space ship right and
there are there's a meteor coming right
here and one right here and there is a
gold coin right here let's make this
gold right so let's say you get a reward
for collecting the coin but you also get
a reward for shooting the meteors right
so what happens if you shoot right now
so if you shoot then let's say you shoot
and this meteor explodes right so you
get a reward yeah
so one reward but then the meteorite
behind it will hit you right it's coming
toward you you'll have no way no time to
get out of the way so one reward and
then death right let's make a little
arrow here right so in total you get one
reward now what happens instead if you
move to the right so move right so the
next in the next frame the meteor will
fly past you you are over here right but
the gold coin is here now this has given
you so far zero reward right this has
given you
zero reward but then in the next frame
you know these meteors have passed now
and you are going to get that gold coin
and that gives you one reward and know
that right so you can technically go
along here and maybe you'll get five
more rewards down the line so the this
is here's the exploration exploitation
dilemma if an agent has for some reason
learned that the shooting action in this
situation will give it a one reward and
the move action will give it zero reward
but has not learned to look past it so
this is kind of nebulous here it has
only experienced it has unexperienced
one frame of here yeah his own
experienced one frame of experience it
will say wait a minute
shoot here appears to be like really
good it gives me one reward and move
gives me zero reward so from now on I'll
just always do shoot right shoot shoot
shoot now what you would like to do this
so this is called exploitation right
exploitation it has learned something
that gives it a reward so it will just
do that over and over again
whereas here
you could say uh I might go this way
even though it's zero word because I can
hope right I don't know yet but I can
hope that I will get more reward down
here this is exploration and the
question in reinforcement learning is
always how to trade off these two right
ideally you would want your agent to
collect maximum reward that speaks for
exploitation of what it has already
learned but also you never want to
discard the possibility that down the
line of things that you don't yet know
there might be even more reward and that
speaks for exploration I'm just that
this both are abbreviated the same
exploit explore this was done so in the
original deep QN formulation and I
believe also in r2d2 this is done with
epsilon greedy which is surprisingly
performing well
so in epsilon greedy you simply say I'm
going to have a constant epsilon this is
e epsilon and this is maybe five percent
or something I'm going to simply do
something at random and the other one
minus epsilon I'm just going to go with
the with the thing I have already
learned and this performs pretty well
but you might imagine that there is
something smarter to do so never give up
these this algorithm it kind of goes
into this exploration mode where it
tries to get get to smarter ways to do
exploration and the key words here are
things like intrinsic motivation so
intrinsic motivation and curiosity refer
to the fact that it is so
in addition to the reward you get from
the environment here right this is this
reward right here you can also interject
at this point and say ah I'm going to
give some r-prime some reward of myself
right to to kind of encourage some
behavior in the agent and this here we
call intrinsic in trinsic so that means
you add to the reward of the environment
you add some reward of your own that has
nothing to do with the environment or
not much but just encourages certain
behavior in the agent that is now also
trying to maximize this intrinsic reward
and in curiosity and intrinsic
motivation formulations usually you are
rewarded for novelty which means the
agent is rewarded for finding things
that it has not yet seen so you in this
situation over here you might see why
this encourages the agent to go this
route here because it says wait a minute
there's a bunch of stuff like here I
just died right but there is a bunch of
stuff I haven't seen yet down here so I
might want to go explore it and we give
it extra intrinsic reward our prime for
seeing things it hasn't seen yet
so it will learn if I do things that I
have never done I will get this sweet
intrinsic reward and then it will go
explore now of course it's a it's a big
engineering question of how exactly to
set this intrinsic reward and there are
many many different formulations of that
that fall under this term of let's say
curiosity or something like this
nevertheless this never-give-up has has
improved overall 2d2 using ideas like
that and now agent 57 improves again now
how does agent 57 improve again and it
is mainly it is mainly in Indy Indy in
this what I just said so how exactly do
you apply this intrinsic reward how
exactly do you navigate the exploration
exploitation trade-off
that's where agent 57 comes in because
what they've realized this that for
these different Atari games right here
some are very easy some you don't need
much exploration some you need a lot
some you need it over a large time scale
and simply one agent one never give up
agent with the same settings of this
curiosity of how long it looks into the
future is not going to solve all the
games
so agent 57 learns how to to modulate
this exploration exploitation trade-off
so let's jump into the paper a bit more
I encourage you to read the blog post
that is quite thorough and the paper is
a bit more technical sorry let me switch
over this is the paper agent 57 up
forming the Atari human benchmark by
google deepmind and here they say
improvements to end you two never give
up
so the first improvement they do is so
if we've already talked about how this
is classic q-learning
right so you're trying to learn this
function that gives you the Q value of
an action and the state now since we're
going to deal with intrinsic reward in
addition to extrinsic reward it makes
sense that's what they argue to split
the Q learning function into two
different parts one part that learns the
extrinsic reward and one part that
learns the intrinsic reward
right and then you have a parameter data
in front of it now beta in this case is
the trade of how much do you want to
value this intrinsic reward right and
here we see our first lever on the
exploitation exploration trade-off if an
agent gets lots of reward for haha for
exploring right it might never exploit
and exploiting might actually be a good
a good option in the game that you're in
so you might want to set better small
but in other games you might want to
encourage exploration to the max and
they're there for a set beta very high
alright another constant along with that
that they modulate is the is the
discount factor so which is called this
gamma here so you already see here this
better we've already seen and they also
modulate this gamma now what does gamma
do if I have my state and action we
already said so here is an observation
one and I do action one and that gives
me observation to and I do action two
and that gives me observation three and
I do action three and each time I get a
reward right an extrinsic reward and an
intrinsic reward so reward one reward to
reward three and so on
now usually in our L agent we'll look at
these rewards and let's say you are here
you are at observation one and you're
trying to estimate your future rewards
what will be most important will be the
reward that you're getting right now
right because that's the most sure
because this reward here that you might
get two steps from now you know a lot of
things could happen
right you are pretty sure that if you do
action one you're going to get to this
state but you're not entirely sure you
could also get to another state and
therefore you had to do another action
and therefore this reward here could be
something different so these algorithms
are are having what's known as a
discount factor that means the value of
a state of a state s is going to be the
sum from time 0 let's say K equals T
that's the state at time T up until some
horizon I think they call it h in the
paper you could also think of this as
infinity of the reward at step K but
discounted by this factor and you raise
it to the to the power of K usually or t
t - ؈ K minus T so basically means that
you this is if T is 1 so it's the reward
at the at this time step plus let's say
gamma here is 0.99 right plus 0.99 the
reward at the next time step plus 0.99
squared the reward of that after that
and you see that the more the more into
the future you look the less value these
rewards have so little bars here
indicate that you're going to value
future rewards less and less this is
called a discount factor right here and
it's how to set it is very important
because if you set it very low let's say
you set it to 0.1 that means all that
you want to do is maximize the rewards
that you're getting in the like
the next and next next step you're not
really looking into the future this is
very good for games that give you
immediate reward for good actions but if
you if you set it very high let's say
0.999 right that means a reward a
hundred steps from now doesn't you know
it is almost the same to you as a reward
one step from now and this is very
valuable for games that don't give you a
reward immediately or that kind of
trying to trick you as we saw before
like if you shoot the meteor now then
you get one reward but if you don't and
pass on the opportunity you might get
much more later so the modulation of the
discount factor is also very important
to set and really depends on the game so
we have two quantities here that really
depend on what kind of game it is
and also they argue it it also depends
where in the learning process you are so
if you're at the very beginning of the
learning process you might want to have
a very high goal the high intrinsic
reward to go explore and you won't might
want to get have a very low discount
factor in order to learn a good
immediate value function but then as
time goes on you might want to bring
down the intrinsic reward because now
you really want actually because your
end goal is to maximize the extrinsic
reward and you want to up this discount
factor to look more into the future now
that you have already learned the
immediate values very well so if I had
to summarize and simplify what agent 57
does is it builds a neural network that
adjusts these two quantities across the
training
so so it adjusts the beta and gamma
across the training and it does this in
a so-called bandit setting now there is
no real good picture in this paper that
I can show you so I'm just going to have
to to draw so you have an agent right it
interacts with this environment here and
it always gets these rewards now what
you'll have here is a meta controller
right so the agents it has two
parameters it has this beta and this
gamma and the meta controller now
observes this it observes this
interaction and it outputs values for
these two constants and it does this
dynamically as the training progresses
right so the the agent the agent will
will kind of learn the agent will change
its behavior over time now this is
actually implemented in a slightly
different way in that the meadow
controller doesn't control the values
directly but it it has kind of options
so what you do is you define a bunch of
possibilities for beta and gamma so you
say I have strategy one strategy one has
beta at 0.1 and gamma at 0.9 strategy
two has beta at 0.2 and gamma at 0.8 and
so on right and now the Tomato
controller has to choose between one of
these in this case six different
strategies across training so it might
start off as we said with a high beta
which might be over here point nine
point one it might start off with a high
beta and then transition to the lower
ends and it can do so depending on the
game and depending on the progress in
the game so this is this is dynamic and
this is the improvement over never give
over this other agent because this other
agent simply had these strategies and
trained them at the same time and now
this meta controller here controls which
strategy is currently trained and which
one is used to generate the experience
so this is this is basically I mean
there's a they also of course they also
say well we also increase the window of
let me go back
so this LS TM these these I've I've
shown you these things here that
incorporate experience over time they
also say well we increase the the window
of how long the LS TM the time window of
how much experience is incorporated and
they do a bunch of other things which I
always find kind of annoying because
it's always really really hard to see
where the improvements come from that
they claim they made so but you know
barring that basically they built this
made a controller to choose the
strategies for the agent over time now
of course this made a controller again
is trained by the rewards that you get
back from the environment so the meta
controller as an action has the choice
of strategy right and the reward it gets
back from the agent environment
interaction right so in itself it is a
reinforcement learning problem now why
like it to me it seems just shifts the
it just shifts the problem of
exploration exploitation one level
higher they use a sliding window bandit
algorithm to do this but again you have
hyper parameters they're like how long
is the sliding window and
- how does the bandit algorithm do the
exploration exploitation trade off so it
seems to me you're just shifting it one
level higher and it also seems like
we're getting into the region of where
we are meta over-engineering our
approaches to the specifics of this Tory
benchmark because we're kind of
observing oh okay these agents do this
wrong these agents do this wrong so
let's just build an agent that can do
both sort of and then the kind of odd
astok thing I find that they open with
how to measure artificial general
intelligence which I mean come on you're
just it's kind of a mystery now you're
just kind of over and over and over
fitting on this one benchmark there's
not really a need to to make this into a
story on artificial general intelligence
alright so this was my two cents to this
I hope you enjoyed this and bye-bye